He was one of the most influential,
talented entertainers the world has ever seen.
But he was also one of the most complex,
generous and de friends champion of the underdog,
a devoted family man.
But he was also a womanizer.
He was a volatile,
it was loud mouth and he was a tough guy.
He lives in life on the edge of excitement,
danger,
and passionate.
So how did the skinny Italian kid from New Jersey become an international
superstar and the world's first true multimedia artist?
Well,
in this episode of biographics,
we go behind the veneer to get up close and personal with the chairman of the
board,
Francis Albert Sinatra.
I was born on December the 12th 1915 Hoboken,
New Jersey.
He was the only child of Italian immigrants,
Martin and Dolly Sinatra.
As such,
he was pampered by his parents.
He lavish the best of what they could afford on their son.
Still Little Frankie grew up lonely and alone.
Martin Sinatra was a down to earth,
easy going and hardworking city fireman.
His mother was just the opposite,
driven,
involved in political issues and proving herself the driving force of the
family.
She belongs to every organization in Hoboken and had a reputation as an
extremely dominating character.
While both of his parents worked young frank to look after himself,
if he wasn't home alone,
he'd be out wandering the neighborhood where he quickly discovered how to become
street smart.
He grew up in the welds of prohibition,
bootleggers and speakeasies school was never a priority for the teenage frank.
He would often skip class to hang out in pool halls,
boxing gyms,
and on street corners.
He seemed developed a reputation as a stubborn,
ornery kids who would never back to down often the subjects of racial taunts.
He would never,
that's an insult pass a friend recalled is that once he and frank were walking
down the street,
when someone said,
hey,
you little wop to frank,
his friend told him to keep on walking,
but an enraged frank blurted out,
I'm going to walk all over his face.
The only problem was that frank didn't really know how to fight and he
subsequently got beaten to a pulp when his friend Austin,
whether it was worth it,
he replied,
hell yeah.
He'll never call me a walk again.
However,
two days later,
the same thing happened.
Same Guy,
same results.
By the age of 16 frank had ditched school altogether.
He works at a series of odd jobs,
including as a dock worker and a newspaper boy,
but he often got boards and we quit a solid job after just a few weeks when he
walked out on a job working in the refrigeration units of cargo ships.
His father had had enough.
He referred to his son as a quitter and told him,
if you want to be a bum,
go somewhere else and be a button.
Frank didn't have to be told twice.
He packed up his few belongings in a suitcase and took the train to New York
City.
By now,
he had set his sights on making it as a singer,
but no doors opens for the skinny Italian get.
He couldn't find any employment at all,
let alone a singing gig with nowhere to stay and no money for food he had at
home.
I would leave.
Dolly mocked her son singing ambitions,
referring to him as mister bigshot before smacking him on the head,
but behind the scenes she began visiting clubs and asking managers to give a by
a chance.
This resulted in a short term Gig in Hoboken club,
but the job isn't lost.
Frank got in a fight with the proprietor and was shown the door when he was 17
Dolly and Marty frank,
$65 so that he could buy a portable address system and sheet music arrangements.
This Putin may step ahead of other aspiring club performance.
Frank then blazer began collecting orchestrations.
He later explained his strategy bands needed them.
I had them if the local orchestra wanted to use my arrangements and they always
did because I had a large run up to the minute collection and they have to take
singer Sinatra to in this way frankly managed to establish a foothold in the
local club scene.
His hero was bing Crosby and he tried to copy the Crosby sounds,
but when he noticed virtually every other singer out there was doing the same
thing,
he made the decision to establish his own unique sounds
and the summer of 1934 the 18 year old frank and that 17 year olds in that seat,
Carol Bob Beta,
she came from a poor family in Jersey City and New Jersey.
Nancy was sitting on her front porch doing her nails.
When frank walks up to her with a Ukulele in his hands,
his opening line was,
Yo,
what about me?
I could use a medicare to the spark was lit and the romance blossomed over the
next four years.
They lived one town apart and frank would frequently take the bus to visit and
data.
Nancy.
During these years,
frank was building his thinking experience.
Most of the gigs would pay around $2 a night.
Sometimes he performed at roadhouses for nothing more than a sandwich or a box
of cigarettes.
Frank's first break came on September the eighth 1935 when you auditioned for a
spot on the NBC radio show,
Major Bowes aunties,
original amateur hour.
This show was broadcast live from the Capitol Theater in New York City.
Frank teamed up with a group called the three flashes and they became the
Hoboken four.
They performed the big Crosby hit shine ans one spot on the show,
which was sort of a 1930s for runners to American idol listeners.
Phones in to vote for their favorite acts ends.
The Hoboken four proved so popular.
The major Bowes invited them to return several times.
However,
the radio show appearances didn't lead to any lasting success.
Frank,
Roseanne into Hoboken and soon found himself once again,
begging for jobs anywhere he could find them.
In 1939 frank and Nancy,
they were married not long after that.
Frank was singing in a cloud called the rustic cabin.
In the audience was Harry James and big bands leader who was auditioning for a
lead singer.
James was impressed with Frank's waived walking a lyric invited Sinatra to
audition the next day,
although there were a lot of others who showed up for the job.
When frank opened his mouth,
the matter it was settled,
he made his debut with the Harry James Band on June the 30th 1939 at the
hippodrome theater in Baltimore.
The rest of that summer and into the fall,
he toured with a band too enthusiastic audiences.
By 1940 Sinatra's popularity.
It was growing steadily.
Then he changed bands midstream jumping at the chance to sign on with the more
famous Tommy Dorsey Orchestra.
The deal though,
frank,
structurally it was hardly in his favor.
He would give up a third of his earnings for life plus 10% for Tommy's agents,
but all the young frank who had recently become a father wanted was to sing and
be famous and besides would end up with more each week.
Then he was getting with the old band with this band.
Frank traveled across the country and he ended up in Hollywood,
California.
In 1942 the battens with Sinatra out front made a cameo in the MGM movie ship,
a high with band behind him,
frank and built up his profile if ad on the radio in concert halls,
on TV and in the movies.
By the end of 1942 he was one of the most well known singers in the country and
he had replaced bing Crosby,
has billboard's top of band's vocalist and cut his first record.
Okay.
By the ends of 1942 frank had made up his mind to go it alone.
He was clearly the star attraction of the Tommy Dorsey band,
so while they may have needed him,
he was more than able to hold an audience by himself.
When he told Dorsey of his intentions,
the band leader was furious,
but frank was determines.
Finally Dorsey relentless.
He did insist,
however,
the contract for a third of Sinatra's earnings would remain in place.
Frank decided that he would worry about that contract later.
For now,
he would get out before Dorsey,
you changed his mind.
It's an ultra meet his solo debut on his 27th birthday,
December the 12th 1942 in the audience that night was Bob Whiteman manager of
the paramount theater.
He was so impressed that he asked Benny Goodman the king of swing,
if he minded having frank on a bill with him at the paramount Goodmans response
as well as who the hell is Frank Sinatra?
Well,
he would soon find out it's an ultra.
Is it parents?
Is that the power amounts made history.
It was this thoughts if the type of hysteria epitomized by screening and
fainting girls that would later creed Elvis and the Beatles.
When frank at the stage the theater erupted with wild scenes that had never been
seen before in 1944 with his popularity.
Absolutely soaring.
Frank became a father for a second time.
Frank Sinatra Jr joined older sister Nancy at home while their fathers Star
capture sending his record sales tops of the buildings and he was the most
requested voice on the radio
with the end of World War II Sinatra's fame to yet another level.
He was contracted by Hollywood to star in a series of musicals each more popular
than the last.
Yes.
In his personal life,
things were starting to unravel.
He was away from home so much that he hardly saw his wife and children.
Then in 1947 frank met and fell in love with a beautiful and glamorous actress.
I have a gardener.
The two began a very public affair which lost Sinatra wrote quite a lot of
popularity among the older demographic.
At the same time,
the 31 year old crooners voice was beginning to show signs of strain and he was
also being attacked by mainstream media outlets for his support of liberal
causes.
It was sad that his fight against segregation was communist.
Inspired reporters also began claiming that he dodged the draft during the war.
Leading the printer sells on Sinatra was reporter Lee Mortimer.
On April the eighth 1947 the two men came face to face at Ciro's nightclub in
Hollywood.
Frank went straight up to the reporter and calls him a fruit and then proceeded
to use him as a punching bag.
Frank's bodyguards quickly broke his ankle with Sinatra yelling.
Next time I see you,
I'll kill you.
You know,
little degenerate.
Mortimer had frank arrested and charged with assault and battery.
The charge resulted in Sinatra's gun pan is being reversed.
Mortimer later sued for $250,000 and the case was eventually settled for 9,000
yes,
it's an option that never seemed to appreciate that it's choice of associates
could impact his career.
In 1947 not long after he beat up on Morton,
he went to Havana to meet with the mobster boss.
Lucky Luciano.
This mob connection was to stick with him for the rest of his life.
Despite the affair with Ava Gardner,
Nancy Sinatra stuck by her husband's side.
She gave birth to a third child,
Christina on father's day in 1948 but the new edition did not bring frank back
into the family,
fold his fascination with Ava.
It was greater than ever.
I'm like Nancy,
if it could match him,
drink for drink,
cigarette for cigarettes and Tantrum for Tantrum.
They were an ideal hard living couple.
That's how I'm living there.
It had a price.
In 1949 Frank's voice gave out.
That's combines with his public reactions.
He was outrageous affair led to plummeting record sales and shot numbers.
His radio show was dropped and MGM canceled his movie contract.
It looked like the show was over for the man who had been cool with the voice in
1951 Nancy finally divorced from frank in short order Sinatra,
Mary David Gardner.
He had formalized his love life,
but it seemed there was nothing he could do to resurrect his failing Korea.
The public had simply become disenchanted with him.
Viewing him as a washtub has been.
It was.
It was
during his period of hardship in the early 1950s that Sinatra read a book called
from here to eternity by James Jones.
When he learns that a movie version was being plans,
he became convinced that this could be his road back to the top.
He set his sights on securing the role of private Angela Majia.
Frank secure doesn't audition and then proceeded to convince the movies,
producers that he was magic.
He won the pass and he gave the performance of his life.
Sinatra won the Oscar for best supporting actor.
The following month he signed a recording contract with capitol records and just
Korea was back on track.
It's a bit as the losing his fame and then pouring it back had changed Sinatra
as a singer.
He now worries heart on his sleeve.
Sharing in his performances is in a struggles.
He became the first as the best musical storyteller and it was this ability the
brought him the male audience,
but he had never had before in Sinatra.
They swarm for tend to tough guy that they wanted to be.
It's an ultra.
His marriage to Ava Gardner was tumultuous and detention in divorce in 1957 but
his Korea was going from strength to strength by the late 1950s he was well and
truly back on top.
His album come fly with me was number one and it was on the chance for an
impressive 71 weeks.
At the same time,
his movie career was also hitting new heights in the man with the golden arm.
He gave an extraordinary performance as heroin addicted misfit.
The 1960s then saw an emergence of new kinds of popular music,
rock and roll,
realizing that he couldn't ignore us.
Sinatra tried to accommodate by bringing out uptempo albums in the early sixties
snapchat also became a staunch supporter of John F.
Kennedy.
However,
Franklin maintains his association with key mob figures.
Attorney General.
Robert Kennedy was concerned that not brought these underworld criminal figures
too close to the presidents.
He managed to sever the relationship between JFK and Sinatra.
Sinatra.
Last great movie role was 1962 is the Manchurian Kansas in which he played a US
army officer Ben Marco.
After that,
he appeared to become bored with movies and developed a reputation as a trouble
maker.
On the set is this engine had switched to Las Vegas,
then you gambling capitol of the nation.
Then he and his buddies became known as the rat pack along with Dean Martin.
Sammy Davis,
Jr Peter Lawford,
Joey Bishop Sinatra performed the mixture of standup comedy and lounge music at
the best casinos in town.
Then in December of 1963 Sinatra is fun.
Loving existence was jarringly interrupts his when his 19 year old son Frank Jr
was kidnapped and held for $240,000 ransom Sinatra appeal to Robert Kennedy who
called in the FBI.
The ransom was paid.
Frank Jr was released in the has prompted.
He caught with most of the ransom being returns in 1964 while filming von Ryan's
express and ultra notice,
the young actress named Mia Farrow hanging around the set,
the star of a popular nighttime soap opera Faro,
which is 19 scene became Sinatra's constant companion via 30 year age gap
provided Pennsy for the gossip columnists do get their teeth into.
In 1965 to 50 year old singer won an Emmy for the best television special of the
year following year.
He recorded one of his most popular albums of all time strangers in the night.
That same year,
1966 Sinatra and mia were married.
However,
me as mellow hippie style was out of step with Frank's hard living ways and the
union and he lasted for 16 months following the divorce and finding himself in
danger of being yesterday's news.
Sinatra began looking for a new musical direction that will allow him to compete
with the hard edge rock and roll that was popular at the time.
He found what he was looking for in the song my way written by Paul Anka.
The song which frank recorded in 1969 has become his anthem.
Then in 1972 the shock of his legion of fans,
Sinatra announced his retirement.
He said that he was tired of show business and once it nothing more than to
relax,
read,
and think that just as he repaired to take his life easy life threw another
curve ball his way.
He was summoned to a congressional hearing.
Keen to investigate has connections with the mafia,
lack of evidence for us that you congressional committee to drop its
investigation and the heat went off.
Sinatra reassignment though it never sat easily with frank cans.
By 1973 it was once again on the comeback trail.
This time is focus would be on concert performances.
He leapt back into the public consciousness with a television special called old
blue eyes is back from there.
He went on to fill all of the concert halls and big arenas across the country.
He's saying directly to his audience,
dressed in a fitted Tuxedo.
Just see it always done.
In 1976 the 60 year olds,
Sinatra married for the fourth time,
his bride was 45 year old Barbara Marks.
She traveled with him as he played two ever growing crowds.
By the 1980s the chairman of the board is a bonafide icon.
He went on to help in Ronald Reagan's campaign.
Then in 1988 the 73 year old pads with some of his former Ratpack performance.
The audiences absolutely loved it.
In 1993 Frank Nitti use of a technological innovation to produce an album
entitled Frank Sinatra do apps.
He sang along with 13 top recording artists.
They were at different places and times the record became a number one pattern
of best seller and outsold any of his previous recordings.
It's an ultra lived out the last five years of his life in relative quiet.
He was plagued by ill-health often going into hospital with cardiac complaints.
Then the dementia set in.
He passed away on May the 14th 1998 at a hospital in Los Angeles with the
official cause of death being Hashtag on May the 15th the Empire State Building
was turned to blue in New York and the casinos in Las Vegas came to a holes in a
tribute to the man who very uniquely did it his way.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that will send
you a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the right and as always,
thank you for watching.